we have some breaking news this  afternoon and that is that the royal air  force have confirmed that typhoon jets  have been scrambled to respond to what  they're calling an unidentified aircraft  approaching the united kingdom the jets  um took off from raf lossy mouth in  murray in scotland and they were joined  by a voyager air-to-air refueling tanker  and that aircraft went from raf bryson  norton in oxfordshire  an raf spokesman has declined to prefer  to provide any further detail on the  operation until it is over so as soon as  we have any more information from the  raf we'll bring that to you so just to  update you the raf says typhoon jets  have been scrambled to respond to an  unidentified aircraft approaching the uk